morning live from Southeastern turkey
there's a desperate need for Aid here in
turkey and also in Syria following the
earthquake that's now known to have
killed more than 21
000 people
this morning we're at a sports center
that's become a makeshift Aid facility
in adiaman where tens have also been put
up for the survivor's Anger from those
who've lost loved ones over the time
it's taken for Aid to reach them is
palpable here from the people we've been
speaking to the UK has revealed plans to
build a failed hospital and has sent
thousands of thermal blankets to Turkey
as International efforts step up we'll
be speaking to people throughout the
program both those trying to deliver
food and water here of course and also
to these survivors first some breaking
news for you though on the economy and
the UK has narrowly avoided a recession
let's get more with Paul good morning
Paul
good morning yes we've had the latest
figures for GDP economic output how the
economy is doing from the office for
National statistics this morning these
are the monthly figures for December and
crucially for those keeping the UK's
economic scorecard the quarterly figures
for the end of last year and while
growth contracted the economy shrank in
December by half a percent strikes and
snow contributing to a very difficult
month across the board in the economy
the quarterly figure showed flat growth
zero growth didn't grow it didn't shrink
and that means the UK has on the
technical definition avoided a recession
a recession is two consecutive quarters
of economic contraction the economy
getting smaller while it shrank in the
third quarter of 2022 it was flat in the
final quarter of the year so the UK
isn't yet in recession but there is not
a lot of good economic news here facing
huge challenges across the board the
chancellor with public sector strikes
still raging his own own party calling
for tax cuts business desperate for
incentives to start investing money in
the UK I'll be talking to him in the
next hour to hear what he plans to do
about it
okay let's return now to the earthquake
um that has of course hit uh turkey and
Syria which is why we are here the new
development this morning is that the UK
is sending Medical Aid and specialist
equipment to Turkey thousands of thermal
blankets have been sent overnight on an
RAF transport plane further support will
arrive in the coming days which will
include
amongst other things a field hospital
with a 24-hour operating theater and a
specialist critical care support team
more than 21
000 people now confirmed dead across
turkey and Syria with tens of thousands
badly hurt following the 7.8 magnitude
quake and subsequent aftershocks
this morning let's start over here
should we um Nathan watch that stick as
you can ask this is one of the many soup
stations it's quite quiet at the moment
we've seen huge queues Gathering here
over the last couple of hours since we
first arrived it's a lentil soup
obviously many people here being a
vegetarian and they often offer it to us
of course we we are reluctant to accept
that given their number of people that
they're trying to help here in the tens
of thousands this is a an aid Hub that
has been set up by the government a lot
of the stuff that is here actually if we
move around we can see um a boss that
has just arrived a coach and that is
absolutely
rampacked with things like blankets and
clothing and shoes it's from Turkish
people a lot of the other eight hasn't
yet arrived the heavy digging equipment
is coming in but the aid hasn't yet
arrived so that is from donations from
from Turkish people who have been
watching this unfold on television
another soup station here as well let me
tell you about the building behind that
is a Sports Hall we will take you in
there a little bit later on but I just
want to tell you what happened it has
been damaged and it was further damaged
during the second Quake so a lot of
people that were inside during the first
Quake to frighten to sleep inside they
are now in a tented City around the back
of the Sports Hall 15 16 000 people also
in a stadium down the road they're in
dorms from the local sports halls and
local schools as well we'll tell you
more about that too come this way I'm
going to join stravone in just a second
in fact Siobhan tell me about this
building that's ahead of us here Siobhan
good morning so yeah you can see the
building yeah these are all residential
buildings and it's interesting because
it brings up one of the points that lots
of people have been talking to us about
and that's why how come some of these
buildings have totally crumbled and then
others are still standing up but you can
see there that's clearly a couch we can
see the back of
um into people's bedrooms as well others
you go past the whole side is missing
and then we drove through the city
yesterday and every single building in
some streets are totally destroyed talk
to me about what's going on here this is
obviously
um Water Aid that is is this is mostly I
we have to say it's from the Turkish
government at the moment isn't it yes so
lots of Aid coming in here this is
bottles of water I've seen on buses here
as well blankets yeah we just talked
about that food coming in water
obviously really important because the
city has lost its water supply
across almost all of it
um but of course it's not just turkey
that's providing this Aid they are also
looking to International partners and
they've actually published a list of
people who have sent search and rescue
teams so we can have a look at the list
now but Azerbaijan actually has sent the
most Personnel they've sent
725 and obviously they're an earthquake
uh pronation as well so lots of
expertise there the US has offered a
rescue team of 159 they've also offered
85 million dollars of humanitarian Aid
and of course we already know that the
UK have sent their 77 strong Rescue Team
they've also sent thermal blankets and
they're looking at setting up field
hospitals uh yeah and we we also believe
actually that the Brits are sending that
field hospital that's going to be 24 7.
it's going to have an operating theater
and it's going to be able to treat other
people as well but that's been
replicated by lots of other countries
yes so here in this city we know that
the French are trying to set up a field
hospital as well okay when the first
earthquake struck in the early hours of
Monday many people were inside their
home sleeping those homes sometimes in
huge apartment blocks as we saw now
literally reduced to Rubble uh in the
coming days and weeks there will
inevitably be questions about how this
amount of death and destruction was
possible so
why didn't they know the risks
so obviously the first thing we have to
say is this is one of the worst
um earthquakes here in a century one of
the worst internationally in a decade so
it was huge but also we have been
looking at information surrounding
earthquakes and we can have a look at a
map and this is the earthquake zone and
when you have a look on that map you can
see the triangles now they actually show
a network which measures ground movement
and Sky News understands that some areas
in some areas the movement from the
Quake exceeded the levels in turkey's
design code right so basically they
couldn't prepare for this level it
actually reached the upper limits of
what would have been expected in every 2
500 years and then we can show you
another slide and this is focusing on
gaziantep which we know of course was
the epicenter and it looks at some of
the most vulnerable neighborhoods there
and on that graphic you can see the
darkest color now that's predicting uh
some is in the most vulnerable areas
there is predicting that over half of
the buildings would suffer but this was
based on a quake which was 10 times less
powerful than the one that struck so you
can imagine just how much more damage
was done yeah I was chatting oh you were
with me actually yesterday when we saw
that apartment block that had literally
collapsed like a house of cards some
eight stories high many hundreds of
people thought to have died and we were
just about to go to our at nine o'clock
in the morning when this lady absolutely
Furious about what had happened with
that building stopped to talk to us
the builder of the building
and we get our homes
that was a lady that I was speaking to
yesterday she was telling me that
literally they've been giving the
Builder bags of money and they've taken
out a central column hadn't they Siobhan
and as a result the building collapsed
she was talking to lots of other people
yeah so um some of the people that we
met who were waiting to see if their
relatives were going to be found alive
in that building some of them had
already had the news that they hadn't
survived and they invited us to watch
some of the funerals that were taking
place and many of the people that we met
at those funerals were Furious about the
buildings and the weakness in the
buildings they said that their lives
have been put at risk one person told me
he believed this was essentially murder
because of not enough work being done
just to explain what's going on
obviously vehicles are moving around all
the time here we are trying to bring you
a flavor of what's Happening while
trying to stay out of the way they are
doing essential work here 20 000 people
being helped this is the hub for this
area of Ariana sorry gone and you can
see it's so frenetic because obviously
so much Aid is needed that's why they're
coming in and out like this because it
is desperate and we know that people
here have said that they didn't get much
support from outside for two days now as
I was saying I went to witness some of
these funerals and you can have a listen
now to what some of the people here were
telling me
[Music]
turkey is burying it's dead
loved ones crushed while they slept
children parents partners
the loss is profound
This Woman's daughter is among those
killed
when her body was found she had her baby
in her arms
the pain is too much
I wish I died and my children had lived
she says
[Music]
grief Echoes around adiaman
the earthquake totaled much of the city
but people say it took two days for help
to arrive
by which time the voices below the
rubble had fallen silent
so the body bags keep arriving
50 here in an hour
and with them the anger mounts
foreign
curses the president she says she hears
her nephew begging for help from the
wreckage help that never came
but others are still waiting for news
[Music]
when this apartment collapsed homes
became tombs
as Rescuers search for The Hundreds
still missing
distraught relatives watch on
CE
the only thing we have is hope the mood
tells me so we wait to the end
six of his family are buried here he has
little else to lose
whole families died in this collapse
Generations wiped out and this is a
pattern which is repeated tens of times
in this city
thousands of times across turkey
[Music]
for now they will mourn their dead
but with each new coffin the same
question
if help had come sooner
could this life have been saved
[Music]
so we just want to move back to where we
can see the food Aid position here
because we do have a couple of people
that have volunteered to talk to us so
wandering uh with Siobhan uh Siobhan
just as we wait to speak to these people
um talk to me about just remind me what
Aid has come in so far and what we're
expecting so you can see here lots of
Aid coming in there's um here stuff
that's come from the government but also
we've seen lots of Aid coming into the
city from various volunteers different
city groups have driven to areas that
are in Need For example so we can see
bread here but also there's the
international Aid that's been going on
as well so Azerbaijan we were talking
about they are sending the most
Personnel more than 700 from there the
US is donating more than 85 million in
humanitarian Aid we've got the UK of
course which have sent those 77 strong
team which one of our colleagues Alex
Crawford filmed with as well so which of
these gentle woman who is it that wants
to speak to us
who would like to talk to us hello sir
hello
um tell me um how you've come here and
what you are doing
guys
they are coming from the arbor Kush they
worked in the first days in the arbor
Cruise earthquake area by the buildings
by the Ruggles and then afterwards they
heard that adiaman is much worse than
the other so there will actually come up
here and what are they doing here is
on the first day we worked on on the
ground with the Ruggles but then here we
are trying to build up tents uh there
are many many volunteer donations coming
up to this location we are trying to
organize and give support to the people
who came here lots of Aid coming now is
it enough
um
we only had the first day we had some
tents
but the support the coming AIDS Foods
clothes
Etc now enough and they are coming and
coming and how long does he plan to stay
here
we are all teachers sad
and the schools will be open at the 20th
of February until then we will stay here
and help people what would you like to
say to people who are watching us around
the world this morning
[Music]
um
foreign
okay
um he says to all the people watching
from the world uh all of these people in
andiaman all in Turkey Turkey lost their
homes so they will need money they will
need support we need solidarity he says
thank you for your help here thank you
very much indeed
so the appeal has obviously uh in full
swing here but of course Daniel Craig
you may have noticed is also launching
an appeal for more aid from not only the
UK from Russia around the world
as the attempts to save more people
under the rubble continue
the Big Challenge ahead is to help the
millions who have survived it
the humanitarian situation is expected
to get worse in the coming days
countless injured need vital medicine or
hospital care
and those now homeless face the freezing
winter without any shelter food or clean
water whatever you can manage every
penny will make a difference so please
donate now
the trauma cannot be undone but we can
and we must help
and a reminder that you can watch a
special documentary disaster Zone the
turkey Syria earthquake half past nine
tonight here on Sky News
we will obviously go inside you what's
happening here tell you to show you the
tents where people are living and also
talk to other people around the site in
the coming minutes and hours before that
let's move on to other news for you nay
and labor has held on to its seat in
West Lancashire after a by-election
victory which saw Ashley Dalton become
the country's newest MP Ms Dalton
secured a majority of 8
326 over her conservative rival with a
10 and a half percent swing from the
Tories to labor
I think what we've seen tonight is that
they're definitely losing votes in the
country and they no longer have that
mandate to govern and Richie soon
doesn't have a mandate to lead so if
this government wants to limp on without
a proper Democratic mandate and push
things through Parliament maybe they'll
do that but I think the message that has
come tonight from the British people is
that time is up for this conservative
government and we do need a general
election
it's been exactly two weeks since The
Disappearance of Nicola bully the lady
in Lancashire she went missing while
walking her dog along the river in Saint
Michael's on wire in Lancashire after
dropping off her two children at school
after extensive searches her whereabouts
remain a mystery
police believe that she fell into the
river wire they've now moved their
search to the coastline teams are
scouring the coastline 10 miles
Downstream from where she was last
spotted
and in other news the former culture
secretary and Nadine Doris of course
we're hearing news about her this
morning and that is that she has decided
not to stand at the next general
election Ms Doris has been MP for Mid
Bedford church since 2005 and in recent
years has earned a reputation as one of
the most loyal supporters of the former
prime minister Boris Johnson
ambulance workers including call
handlers are walking out across five
regions in England today
the workers who are all members of
Unison are demanding better pay and
conditions
former U.S vice president Mike Pence has
been summoned to testify in a criminal
case it's an investigation against the
former president Donald Trump The
subpoena was served on Mr pence in
relation to Mr Trump's bid to overturn
his 2020 presidential election defeat
no it's been four days since the
earthquake struck in the early hours of
Monday morning here in Southeastern
turkey and with every passing hour hopes
fade of finding anyone alive but we have
witnessed rare moments when people are
lifted from the rubble in one case we
saw a woman saved whose family had
started to prepare her burial plot
our International correspondent John
Sparks has the latest for us now from
Mirage this epicenter of the earthquake
and a warning
his uh images do contain
some moving images of people being
removed from the rubble
the air is soaked in dust and smoke
the city marked with concrete Mounds
but in this apocalyptic State there is
evidence of life
human beings still breathing in the
rubble
foreign
we saw an Israeli Rescue Team exploring
the remains
one of the first International groups to
reach caraman Mirage
and they had made a life-saving
discovery
[Music]
a young woman had been rescued from the
Gloom her name zayap chivi
she was fast asleep when the earthquake
struck dressed in polka dot pajamas
we could see her shivering and crying
after her three-day ordeal
we're here we're here don't be afraid
said a paramedic
her younger sister elif followed right
behind the 20 year old was also
shivering
The Rescuers were elated and the family
Overjoyed praying for a miracle they'd
been delivered to thank you very much
thank you very much
his name is Burak and he told us he's
the girl's cousin
[Music]
Mr or did you still have hope in your
heart we thought they were dead we
prepared the burial plot
the Israeli said the sister's survival
owed much to Chance some information
from an earlier success
we pulled out a man named Hussein he was
65 years old
and he told us that he heard voices
and we penetrated the additional room
and we didn't find anyone
but we decided to return to this
building again
maybe he was right
so it was not so close but we found two
women here
we've just come around the corner it's
the same building but the contrast could
not be any greater these are local
people they are using
crowbars and Spades
to try and get access to the building
they want to do the same thing they're
trying to to save people's lives they're
trying to retrieve bodies but it is
going to take them much much longer to
do it
they can smell and in some cases see the
bodies but it doesn't mean they can get
them out what is happening here
we can smell a body here says this
volunteer the body is lying on a bed so
we're trying to dislodge it
the victims make an undignified trip to
a sports stadium for identification
some go by hand
others in diggers
while the injured go to local hospitals
like this one which has turned its
reception into a giant Ward
here we met a relative of zayap and elif
and we asked him how they were doing
normal no injuries said cousin qasim
chivett but they're bruised and cold and
they're trying to revive them
Specialists and supplies have begun to
arrive here but they can't meet the
demand in this traumatized City
John Sparks Sky News in caraman marash
John Sparks reporting that meantime we
are in adiaman and this is the latest
delivery of clothes donated by the
Turkish people
it's collated and then brought here to
this rescue center which is a former
Sports Hall made into a makeshift Aid
Center for now there's food there's
water there's protection against the
elements but what a lot of these people
need are clothes when the earthquake
struck in the early hours of the morning
they literally run out of their homes
with the clothes they were standing up
in I saw an elderly lady just a few
moments ago trying on a pair of shoes
she didn't have anything else and they
quite clearly were not shoes that would
fit her comfortably but she was just
thankful for the chance to have her feet
protected from the cold floor and then
she is actually staying in I think she's
I'm writing saying she's staying in the
sports center at the moment all of them
up to about 20 000 people here at the
moment they are hoping to be able to
find better accommodation in the coming
days and weeks we'll speak to a family
like that in just a second as we pan
around here please if we may uh Nathan
and look at the pals
um of Aid and support this little one
here
managing to smile despite everything
yeah calling for his mummy I'm sure
she's not far away and other gentlemen
here sorting out
um
the sort of products that they will need
going into the next few weeks there's a
lot of Sanitary products we've seen
there's a lot of towels coming through
as well um just things to be able to
wash themselves people as I said if you
look at the buildings we hide you know
they literally fled from these buildings
they describe themselves as lucky ones
because they did escape with their lives
the latest death toll up to 21
000 both here in Southeastern turkey
also in Syria as well and that number
will undoubtedly rise still further just
watching the children's blanket as we go
by I want to chat to Saud here is sewed
with his family
their story
[Music]
is
we could escape from our house the house
is not so well but it's okay it's still
standing on his feet he says but it was
terrible the earthquake during the night
my children were in the rain during the
night it was cold and wet and they were
very scared of their cake
our neighbors help us or they put us
foreign
chocolate
I'm very sorry
they have three children
[Music]
my boyfriend
they won't only see the house again how
can my viewers help them
is
support and help and AIDS I know from
many many countries Aid is coming
towards turkey
foreign
[Music]
continuing coverage here on Sky decision
hello again uh welcome back to adiem and
uh Siobhan is still with me as Siobhan
that was an incredibly emotional
interview that we just stood with that
family my goodness me we can see that
hello so food arriving all the time I
think that's a kebab isn't it yes a
kebab and people you know also having
tea here just trying to make them as
comfortable as possible because as you
said in your interview that you just did
is so difficult for people particularly
when they've been displaced they're
living you know intense in a gym and
they can go back and see the damage
that's happened to their homes and I
think we often see these huge numbers 21
000 have died Millions displaced but
it's until you hear those personal
stories that it really brings it home to
you you know what is what is happening
to people on an individual level yeah
indeed so um let's bring in unal
cheverkus who is the former Turkish
ambassador to the UK now a member of the
opposition an MP
um hello good to see you thanks for
joining us
um what you make of the government's
response so far it's certainly ramped up
over the last couple of days
well um the red from the outset all the
Civil Society organizations the
municipalities and the government
officials try to reach out to the
earthquake region and in in some cases
of course it has been a little bit
delayed because the earthquake has
affected a very wide area and it is
about 500 kilometers long and it has
affected 10 provinces so it was not
possible to reach out everywhere at the
same moment but after the second day now
it's getting more organized I can see
that this guy news is reaching out to
Panama
I have also noticed that the British
International search and rescue team
arrived from the beginning has tried to
reach out to the victims and to the
people who are under the rubble a team
of 77
people search and Rescuers from the
United Kingdom have arrived in Turkey I
think it was on Tuesday they arrived in
concept and then they were distributed
to several cities in the region starting
from pathai from anti to adiaman and
also to kakama Mirage
and the the the government is now trying
to organize all the assistance all the
international Aid coming from abroad but
also from within the country but now it
has been almost five days now after the
earthquake I think the sustainability of
the survivors is becoming more and more
important because the winter conditions
is becoming simulator
uh We've also a lot of my colleagues
have witnessed
um looting there's been some big
challenges people struggling as you said
to get food and water that is improving
now what more needs to be done both uh
by the Turkish authorities and also the
International Community
we have heard about
the loot under control and the people
are of course being arrested if they are
caught in in a looting event and the
security Personnel is trying to prevent
all kinds of eating activities
um I think from that on the
international Aid they should not focus
on food or any kind of other issues but
the sustainability of the living
conditions there the living conditions
are terrible because there's no natural
gas there's no water no electricity and
the sewage system has destroyed has been
destroyed in at the amount in several
other cities maharash or horse and
I think a portable toilets and all kinds
of other field Hospital availabilities
would be very helpful and I'm afraid
there will be a very huge relocation of
the people who have survived after the
earthquake and this is already the start
the time I I'm told that some 70 000
people have already been relocated I
think these people the survivors are
going to be distributed to the other
cities in the country and the many
people of course will be a willingly
hosting them in their houses
foreign
thank you thank you very much thank you
they're just so kind these people they
have very little and yet they still hand
out soup and food for us thank you thank
you very much sir that's kind thank you
I will take it for him later thank you
thank you I want to bring in John Murray
security manager relief International
um hello to you John there have been a
lot of challenges for people here they
are struggling as we've been saying it's
getting better now but they have been
struggling without food water and basic
human requirements which has led to some
levels of crime and looting here
um how does how do the authorities start
to deal with that gently but
persuasively
all right thanks uh thanks okay
so uh the areas where we're operating
are in southern uh turkey and uh in
Northern Syria
um uh for us we haven't seen any uh any
looting uh observed at um any of our
facilities or the area where we operate
I'm aware that it's been happening but
I've seen nothing but uh compassion and
cooperation from people uh because those
uh uh the people that have been
displaced
yeah uh John talk to me about the fact
that you were in gaziantep when the
earthquake hit can you tell us uh what
you were doing there at the time
okay I was uh I was in gazian tap in
order to uh coordinate with some of our
partners um
we are we partnered with a number of um
medical focused uh ngos so I was there
for uh what was supposed to be a
week-long um visit of training in court
nation and um I was in gazian tap on
Monday morning when the Quake hit
so I was fortunate the building that I
was in
um it suffered minor structural damage
but it was intact
um I moved out of the building into the
street uh and I linked up with uh my
other colleagues to establish whether
they were okay and to um uh to let our
headquarters know but um a lot of other
people were in um a lot more dire
situations than uh than I was like we've
had uh unfortunately we've had a number
of Staff members who were killed in the
Quake so we've lost three we have one
staff member unaccounted for
um and then other people have been uh
displaced from buildings that were
actually collapsing around
did you manage to connect up with your
team because what
well I was fortunate enough to have a
couple of power bank um and my phone
charge so um I moved out into the uh the
snow the weather was uh dismal it was
around zero degrees it was snowing
um and I communicated with those guys on
on WhatsApp
um it was a bit of a challenge because
some uh Communications and power was out
in enough number of locations so it did
take us some time to get in touch with
uh with all of our staff
whatever
okay we will um leave it there thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you you can see um these gentlemen now
handing out uh hot Cups of Tea it really
is bitterly cold here it's so welcome to
the very many thousands of people that
are gathering here in the center of
adiaman with literally nowhere else to
go at this stage uh International Aid is
coming in now it's slower obviously than
that that has been provided by the
Turkish authorities but it's coming they
need more just listen to Daniel Craig
as the attempts to save more people
under the rubble continue
the Big Challenge ahead is to help the
millions who have survived it
the humanitarian situation is expected
to get worse in the coming days
countless injured need vital medicine or
hospital care
and those now homeless face the freezing
winter without any shelter food or clean
water whatever you can manage every
penny will make a difference
so please donate now
the trauma cannot be undone but we can
and we must help
the road in this culture to say no and
it's have to say it's very well received
it's bitterly cold uh here
um back at home we've narrowly avoided
recession Again by that much here's the
chancellor well the fact that we have
avoided recession in fact were the
fastest growing major country last year
shows there is underlying resilience in
the UK economy but we are not out of the
woods inflation is still much too high
that is causing pain for families up and
down the country which is why we need to
stick to our plan to halve inflation if
we do that and play to our strengths in
science and technology we really can be
one of the most prosperous countries in
Europe
uh well let's get more from Brixton
Market
um should we um Ashton is standing by
for us
um what's their reaction there this
morning
to be honest Market Traders say it is no
surprise yes the economy has flatlined
but for many people the primary issue
remains as the chancellor mentioned just
there high inflation and the fact that
prices are rising infinitely and across
the board I've spoken to a market Trader
who has been trading here for 23 years
as the market that's been here since the
1880s he's not quite been here as long
but in 23 years he said he's never seen
it as bad as it is now for example he's
telling his customers to go and buy
their vegetables elsewhere this is a
market Trader that sells fruit and
vegetables to give us an example he said
look yellow bell peppers I used to buy
them for eight to nine pounds a box and
now they're 22 pounds with things like
eggs they used to be four pound fifty
for a dozen and now that's gone up to
eight pounds these are prices these
Traders are really having to balance
whether they're going to pass on that
extra cost to the consumer who they know
are spending their money differently so
you've got cash-strapped consumers who
haven't yet entered this Market but
already we're talking about out a Friday
it's usually a busy day for them and
even at the weekends they're not quite
hitting that Mark when it comes to other
produce that they're suffering with it's
not only eggs and peppers but also
vegetables in general I asked one of the
Traders why that might be he blames
transport costs among many other things
but as the chancellor said not out of
the woods yet
okay but no I said thank you
um forgive me
um looking behind me this is bottled
water that is being sent in by the
authority puts everything in perspective
doesn't it really there is no water
supply here in this city at the moment
620 000 people live here
um 75 or thereabouts of the city has
been badly damaged the other 25 percent
no longer exists let's talk about the
economy economy in the UK and bring in
jagat chatter director of the National
Institute of economic and social
research hello two thank you for joining
us on the program this morning are these
the sort of figures that you were
expecting
and first I just want to say these
absolutely heart-rending scenes um from
turkey and all our thoughts but with the
Turkish and Syrian people at this
terrible time it's very good of you to
broadcast from out there and bring this
Devastation uh more clearly into our
homes
so in comparison with the UK economy
we're not in anything like that kind of
trouble but the economy is behaving much
as we expected
um a flat line so no growth in the last
quarter of last year we now think
there'll be a small contraction in the
first quarter of this year of about
minus point two percent
these numbers are very choppy
um the things that affected activity in
the last quarter of last year is that
Services were down particularly public
savings service so public facing
Services there seems to be some impact
from the strikes there were still supply
chain issues and we hadn't really got
over the effects of the mini budget
which had broiled mortgage and credit
markets all of which were providing a
little bit of downward momentum that'll
probably take us into the first quarter
of this year
and over the course of the rest of this
year we see not a recession which means
a contraction a consistent contraction
across a large number of sectors but
probably the economy not doing very much
so probably slightly above the zero line
but in a way that
doesn't really help all those people
we're just hearing about from Brixton
and other places where where people are
not going to feel materially better off
than they did last year and therefore
are going to feel much worse off than
they anticipated or they did in the
recent past these are not
um very good times to the British
economy
Europe but even Russia is going to do
better apparently uh the UK economy this
year yeah well I I I I I I I think the
Russian economy and state has its own
issues and I'd rather be living in a
democracy uh than than there I've got to
say
um
clearly the kind of countries that are
able to export energy oil and gas at a
time when energy oil gas prices have
shot up so much we'll be doing very well
and we see that across the board the
kind of countries that have to import it
on the margin are materially poorer I
want to imagine that a large part of our
household basket of expenditure and a
large amount of firm's expenditure is
explained by Energy prices so whether
we're buying fruit which has to be
transported here or indeed directly
buying energy all those prices have gone
up so adjusting for that impact were
materially poorer and and the UK has
suffered a larger increase in some of
these Energy prices and therefore it
means that overall we're poorer but I
want to add to that ongoing supply chain
issues frictions in trade that have
materially
degraded since the brexit referendum
it's not something we've sorted that has
meant that our supply constraints have a
bit harder than they have in many other
countries and when we add these things
up as well as the impact of covid in an
economy that was very much focused on
Recreation hospitality and restaurant
work that hasn't recovered our GDP
hasn't recovered the pre-covered level
even we begin to build a picture of why
the British economy is suffering more
than others it's it's not something
anyone takes joy in explaining to people
but it's something that many many
households are suffering from in a
rather distressing manner
okay thank you very much indeed for
explaining that to us here on the
program this morning thank you meantime
uh back here in Southeastern turkey
Siobhan are back with me this is another
one of the soup stations that's been set
up
pots here we've got rice here and then
at the back it's like tomato broth
because obviously it's really really
cold minus three overnight so things to
keep people warm but also to fill them
up as much as they can yeah let's have
another Wonder around the site if we may
there's a lot of big lorries here so
we're being very careful with Nathan as
we walk and talk a lot of water this is
again at the moment from the Turkish
government yeah and it's really
important that this water comes through
because we've been told that most the
water supply in the city has gone
obviously clean drinking water is vital
in disaster zones because we don't want
to have any diseases adding to the
problems particularly when there are we
know dead bodies still on the streets
trapped under the rubble so they're
trying to keep everything clean here
we've got some milk milk as well um
just to try and also bring a little bit
of comfort if you have a familiar
product when you've been pushed out of
your home yeah indeed so um inside the
building there are a lot of people still
Sheltering they've been sleeping there
for some time a lot of others though
there's a tented City around the other
side isn't there they don't want to be
inside this building because they were
inside when the second Quake hit and
there was damage to the building yeah
and if you look at the buildings around
us as well you can see just how much
damage has happened and you I think
people feel that they don't know which
buildings are safe because it's hit and
miss around the city some of them are
still standing some have totally
collapsed and we've seen cracks in the
gym as well people worried if they stay
inside you know some people got out of
the earthquake but then stayed inside
for the second and didn't survive so
they're worried about being inside
understandably and so they feel safer
and tense yeah okay this water supply
arriving all the time let's just
continue it this way a little bit Nathan
if we may
um as I said we will wander around to
the tented city
um a little bit later on
um Aid is arriving now from right around
the world including the UK yes 77 teams
from the UK they're on the ground we've
seen them already working trying to
carry out rescues trying to pull people
out of the rubble we know that the US is
sending uh 85 million dollars worth of
humanitarian Aid help from Azerbaijan in
this city we know that the French are
trying to set up a field hospital we
know the British are trying to set up
field hospitals as well so lots of Aid
is starting to come through I think some
people though are concerned that it took
too long to get here yeah so this is the
overview of what's Happening Here
another Lorry has arrived with more
water that needs to be
unloaded and given to the people here in
adiaman some 20 000 people being helped
at the moment it is a city of 630 000 so
you can see from the maths what else
needs to be done say to you nowhere
[Music]